[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is google home max
it's brand new but you might have
forgotten about it since its
announcement a couple weeks ago so let
me refresh your memory on exactly what
it is so we already had google home mini
this little donut sized puck speaker
this is 49 and then we have google home
this is the original it's about the size
of like a large coffee mug
and it's 119 bucks and then this is
google home max this it's like the size
of probably a watermelon right now
pretty heavy too and this will cost 3.99
so the design here is pretty solid
inside it's it's dual 4.5 inch woofers
behind the mesh here and then dual 0.7
inch tweeters so right off the bat the
biggest advantage to home max having
this cabinet that's so big with so much
more space is dedicated drivers for
dedicated frequencies and when it's
sideways here in landscape mode these
drivers are going to give you stereo
audio which pretty much no other smart
speaker does apple homepod won't even do
that from what i've been told it's a
pretty simple looking speaker it just
kind of blends in you don't really want
it to be too flashy after all so it
comes in two colors black and white or
charcoal
and
chalk up there so you got these lights
in the middle of the mesh and then there
really are no buttons up at the front or
the sides or anything just a single
touch bar at the top you slide left and
right to adjust the volume and you can
touch in the middle to play pause simple
as that and it sits on this little
magnetic circular pad that it comes with
it's pretty dense and then there's some
magnets in the bottom of the speaker
right here and it just kind of slaps
onto the bottom like that and that acts
as an isolation pad so it doesn't rumble
whatever surface it's on which is pretty
cool you have that in a lot of high-end
speakers that sit on bookshelves or on
desktops so it's cool that it comes with
that and what's even cooler is that if
for some reason you buy two of these you
can set them up vertically like
bookshelf speakers and they pair with
each other and each one is a channel in
the stereo audio so you can get some
real separation and these little
isolation pads just slap on the side now
so they can stand up and look great and
now the volume control works with the
correct orientation as well and if you
accidentally turn it upside down
you get a little warning message by the
way the google home is upside down it'll
work best if you turn it over
so i'm gonna do that now the rest of the
hardware if you flip it around to the
back you'll see up at the top is your
mute switch i mentioned i wanted it to
be a button because on the mini you
could get out of sync but now you can't
mute the mics with just your voice
anymore so it's just a switch so i guess
that's less confusing and then the
bottom corner you get your headphone
jack to plug in an external audio source
like a record player or whatever else
you got going on a usbc port
nice i don't know what i'd use it for
exactly but nice i plugged my phone in
it charged which is cool but that's
about it and then you have the power
cable the cable itself on the white one
is like this olive off-white greenish
color not sure why but what i do like
about it is a small end to it meaning
the power circuits are all in the
speaker itself so it leaves room for
other stuff at your outlet unlike the
other two google homes but let's get to
the meat of this which is how does it
sound it is a 400
premium smart
speaker so it better sound great so how
does it sound
it sounds great it gets ridiculously
loud the speakers are 20 times more
powerful than these google home speakers
which is nuts
when you're talking to the assistant it
literally sounds like there's another
person in the room with you it's kind of
trippy hey google how tall are you i bet
if we printed out all my code and
stacked it up
it could get pretty tall since i'm
software that might be the only way to
find out you really get all the benefits
of the dedicated drivers though when you
just listen to music at full blast it's
stupid loud obviously and unless they're
playing music for a party you'll
probably never use it this loud and it
does distort a bit at this volume but at
70 75 volume it sounds great and is
still pretty damn loud the original
google home sounded alright but i guess
let's attempt an audio comparison
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it has a lot of rich punchy bass and a
nice clarity to everything across the
board it is exaggerated like don't get
me wrong it is a v-shaped equalizer
because it's not a reference monitor
it's it's a speaker designed for
listening it's trying to color it up and
make it sound fun so the bass is still
really punchy and impressive and that's
also where these microphones come in
first of all it needs those mics to hear
you say commands from like 20 plus feet
away over the music it's already playing
pretty loud and it does a pretty good
job at that but it also uses those mics
for what's called smart sound see when
speakers get big enough they can produce
frequencies so low that they literally
bounce off the walls in the room you're
in like i'm sure you've been in a room
where the sound just resonates
everywhere and it overpowers everything
else this is supposed to eliminate that
it uses the microphones to measure the
acoustics of the room it's in figure out
how close the nearest wall is so it's
not overpowering you with bass and then
makes its adjustments accordingly it
doesn't seem to make a drastic
difference to me in the way it sounds
like it sounds good anyway but the idea
is really smart it's machine learning
and this speaker definitely likes to be
in the corner of a room in the first
place it's not an omnidirectional
speaker like the home mini or like a 360
degree sound all the audio is going in
one direction so you tend to put it near
a wall or somewhere in the corner and
then let it fill the room from there and
you can also control the sound via the
app so if you want to add more or less
bass than you're already getting you can
do that pretty easily so that's what
you're getting it's a kind of hyper
smart premium speaker you're just
dragging in the best of both worlds most
smart speakers like alexa and the other
google homes don't have the really
really nice rich high quality sound and
stereo speakers but most high quality
speaker systems don't have the machine
learning and the google assistant built
in
unless you could grab a chromecast audio
35 bucks plug it into some existing nice
speakers and then get google home mini
49 bucks and set the default audio
output of the google home to be that
chromecast audio so it's always using
those speakers boom now you have your
smart speakers i really do like this
thing though i'm not gonna lie like i i
already liked the original google home
this thing does all the exact same stuff
the google home does
but sounds a million times better just
makes me more likely to use it more
likely to listen to music on it things
like that if you don't already know
having a google home is like this
never-ending discovery of just asking it
stuff and finding out cool things it can
do hey google play the song that goes
now i really wish that i knew how to
swim all right i'll make a man out of
you by donny osmond
playing on spotify
hey google
stop playing hey google
change your voice
here is an example of my other voice
would you like me to use this one
no is this thing really worth the money
at 400 bucks it's definitely not an
insta buy for most people i say wait
until the apple homepod comes out
not because you might buy that instead
well you might buy that instead but
that's supposed to come out at 350 bucks
and once it does i wouldn't be surprised
to see the price of this drop to match
that they're still pretty different in a
lot of ways google assistant is way
better than siri home pods like half the
size but it'll have some different smart
audio features and i think that'll make
it competitive but if that doesn't
convince you then you'll probably just
be better off getting the original
google home and then you can use the
money you save to buy an actual nice set
of bookshelf speakers or tv speakers or
whatever you want but until then i
actually really like this thing i happen
to fall in the extremely narrow niche of
people who will love it and i do and i'm
keeping it that's been it thanks for
watching talk to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]
you